[Music]
that's
nice yo isn't that the crackhead janitor
that was cleaning up poop the other day
like a hip-hop
pirate you got to be kidding me y'all
thought I was a crackhead janitor huh
yes yeah well turns out I'm a rich ass
celebrity and when I heard about y'all
League not being able to find y'all one
decent respectable citizen to Mentor you
little dudes kind of broke my
so I decided to work out a deal with the
Los Angeles County community outreach
program so you could have football
legend Jason 2 J's Jennings ass your new
head coach Legend man get out of here
dog I know who he is good looking out by
time y'all put some respect on my name
nah he used a fake penis to cheat on
drug test you that same guy who y to
have sex with an undercover cop the
night before a playoff
game yeah and a dude who also won one of
these booing those
mother America loves a
superstar I'm Jason 2 J's Jennings I was
a football legend but once you reach the
Mountaintop of greatness everybody wants
to see you
fall two days this guy smoked damn you
pled guilty to charges of speeding and
damage to city property I'm recommending
community service with The Long Beach
Recreations department I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment you too good for the community
that raised you from the depths
of I football legend Jason 2 J's
Jennings your new head coach leg let me
get a picture with y'all real quick for
Twitter some of y'all going to get some
girlfriends with this right
here ke Karine Jon I've been trying to
get back to touch on you for years know
you've been thinking about me and I know
you've been trying to get in touch with
me CU that pretty much right you just
put a gun in my head relax Jay the
safety was on oh no it wasn't on what
imagine
that before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals oh pretty boy you missing
pass after pass you got on all that
sweet ass swag the next time you come
out here acting like a fake ass rapper
we going to kick your ass off the field
stop acting like you got an album coming
out
[Music]
JJ how you liking this game coach this
is a mess I don't know what I'm doing do
you remember what you were like when you
showed up freshman year you were pain in
the ass I don't want nobody nothing
sound just like me you really want to
win a game stop pushing away your
team let's
go it look like a black princess layer
underdogs all three underdogs on Me 1 2
3 what's my
name
[Music]
I got your masc right here be killer and
squiller two calls for 2 G I found them
chained up in the back of the winter
[Music]
snitches